[Music]
i don't like being recorded i'm out
this episode is a paid promotion of the
plastic pills youtube channel yes
we're fun we're doing a cross
promotional
episode
like the good like the good content
producers we are trying to be i feel
like we're selling out i think plastic
pills is fine on his own
we're selling out to the word the
plastic podcast is selling out to the
plastic pills youtube channel how does
that work it's kind of incestuous
we're selling
us out to
me no me out to us exactly exactly yeah
i'm feeling very used right now
very vulnerable
anyway
if you're wondering what we're talking
about the plastic pills youtube channel
not to be confused with the plastic
pills podcast
has finished and pre-released a
documentary on
project cybersyn
and the cia slash military
coup of allende
government in chile
1973.
correct and i happen to be of chilean
descent even though i knew i knew very
little i learned a lot by watching pills
video which was excellent uh
got a sneak
preview of it uh last week and then it i
think there was still an introduction
that was added that i did watch earlier
today
yeah so very well done good show sir and
i'm not chilean but my ancestors were
from somewhere quite chilly so
cold
well you're you're definitely gonna
chill the atmosphere with puns like that
bro but anyway uh we've rallied the
troops here to discuss not just cybersyn
uh we'll do a bit of that but also
latin american politics a little more
broadly because
i know nothing about it though it it
does often get thrown around by leftists
as
i don't know sometimes some
magical land where there is an actual
left in in contrast to the anglosphere
and i wanted to discuss today the extent
to which that's true
or whether it's a sort of fetish spawned
by our own
political impotence
anyway uh victor
chilean canadian as you just said matt i
guess lived in mexico for a few years at
our guest today
uh you know her as our foucault
correspondent but she's both a political
theorist and a mexican with first-hand
experience of politics
there and now politics here
here is canada
uh so thanks for joining the call mirian
and i hope you can help us out with this
reality check
first question as i guess we're talking
pre-recording we know how victor ensues
the term
latinx but to miriam should we
be using that as the as the pc
descriptor here i don't know why
you will take issue with that
honestly i think it's important to
understand
from a latin american perspective the
fact that um
like women and these minorities are very
harshly and violently marginalized in
the region so i think
it's somehow of an important kind of
battle i guess that's
wage and one in like the symbolic
linguistic like realm i guess i don't
know like uh
i really don't have strong feelings
about it i i think i will take more
issue with the whole
putting
a very broad
region into one single
kind of
world like it's such a big region so i
will say that
it's just very unspecific
tries to highlight
kind of the commonalities
which there are of course
but i think it also erases
the different experiences
of like a very vast
like
portion of land
so it's like uh so it's kind of like
when you just like well to do it do a
video about chili and then you're like
we'll all invite marian cause she's
mexican
yeah it's exactly like that
damn the car well look in my defense uh
the relationship between american mining
companies and chilean miners in the 70s
is hardly different from the
relationship between canadian mining
companies and mexican miners today so
the polarity of our shared hemisphere
has not
changed all that much in the last 50
years unfortunately despite the fact
that
i know that chile and mexico as you
point out are geographically and
culturally distinct so thank you very
much i'll also just say i'm not i don't
really like the term latinx very much i
mean
but i'm not gonna get like angry about
it if people like want to use it but it
just it feels very forced and
performative and it feels like it was
just invented by like woke white people
is it a gender is the gender pronoun
right because legit
and latina have gender connotations so x
i don't know i would like to just speak
up on behalf of the logicians and
mathematicians who use variables on a
regular basis and don't appreciate their
tools being appropriated for your
politically correct ends yeah exactly
i'm just kidding
i think there is something that unites
latin america as a region though uh and
i learned this watching a lot of michael
bay movies and it's that the minute you
go immediately south of the rio grande
there's this kind of yellow orangish hue
that just overtakes you and having lived
in the country for several years i can
testify to the existence of this orange
hue that kind of colors everything and i
know that this carries on all the way
down to the falkland islands and then
stops abruptly and things go back to
normal
i saw sicario also and it was very uh
orange
um no like i don't know mexico city has
very shitty air quality and it does get
like very weird color sometimes but no
of course it's not as bad uh but why
would you take issue with the latin i
don't know if i want to dwell into this
but i just wanted to hear victor's
opinion on why you
don't like you don't like the term
i just don't i just think it just feels
forced it feels like invented by
i don't know if there's a need i mean i
also think that the spanish language is
is you know there's a masculine and
feminine in the language and it's just i
don't know it's like it's just weird it
just feels weird and it feels like it
was invented by non-spanish speakers to
be honest
but i think that's a problem right like
it's so much easier to be gender neutral
when you are an english speaker than
when you are a spanish speaker so i
guess that's why like there is a lot
there's also a big fight honestly that
i'm aware of at least in mexico between
like um trying to use more
gender-neutral like uh language and
precisely some of the people kind of
what eric said like uh some of the
people that resist trying to be more
inclusive like say that is not
grammatically correct or that you are
like transforming the spelling and stuff
they are very anti like sorry they
usually
quote the
academy of spanish language which is
kind of a colonial institution
so it's very interesting how this rests
on like very like the this kind of like
powers right uh
the truth is like it's it's it's it's a
very open debate that i see like even
people like
for example me as a spanish speaker
like i find it difficult to include it
on an everyday
like
basis when speaking spanish i don't have
trouble using it in english because if
kind of like i don't know as you said it
kind of feels like
like anglo english term and spanish is
more difficult but i also don't like the
whole i just using masculine to name
everyone you know like in this context i
will have no like no trouble because
most of you are guys but if
that gender was like reversed i would
not like to name everyone as male when
the majority will be female i i don't
know there is a whole debate there i i
think i i will just say but like not to
dwell on this too much that as generally
my opinion about this is
um i was kind of talking about the the
statue issue the other day with a friend
of mine where like should they take down
the statues of people or whatever i feel
similar about the statues as i do about
latinx and that like ultimately i think
people who are like get very emotionally
attached to like one side or the other
about these debates is just kind of like
stupid it's like
ultimately like i just don't care so
like so like i'll say that like i don't
like latinx but ultimately like to have
a strong opinion to be like i really
don't like it and to get angry like that
would be so stupid too right it would be
so stupid to be like i hate it and it's
ruining the language like who cares like
like spend your time on something else
like i don't know or like we're going to
take down the dundas sign in toronto
which because it's like uh
because i guess they were involved in
the residential schools that affected
indigenous people like how about just
spend the money that you have to spend
on taking down those signs and just get
how about fix the water systems or
contribute that money to the wat to like
just like this is all symbolic nonsense
and as like a soulless
liberal globalist who doesn't believe in
anything sentimental i think this is all
just a waste of time who gives a [ __ ]
there you have it that sounds like
something an anglophone would say sorry
sorry angle x phone
a latino perspective
well that is a latino perspective but
now we're damned to offend either way so
maybe we should just wrap it or just say
latin american how about or latin it's
the masculine plural that's the problem
you have to refer to everybody in the
masculine plural even if it's a mixed
group so it's seen as like the male
gendering dominating so there are more
women and there are more women in latin
america than men that's also like oh
there you go
should actually just switch it to make
the female
latinas for mixed groups that's what
they should do that's what i've located
for like yeah 15 100 some odd years with
one we'll just do 1500 years with the
you could also just say latin look like
you don't even need like that's the
other thing it's like you don't even
need the word latinx like like this x
thing i also don't like this well then
i'm gonna be confused are you talking
about thomas aquinas like he's dead for
hundreds of years why latin who the [ __ ]
is that they don't exist
are you sorry st augustine is in the
conversation now all right all right do
you think the french are having this
debate because they can't even add an x
to the end of the third person plural
it'd be
xla
anyway anyway we will move on we'll move
on so
to those of you who did watch the
upcoming feature
i'm trying to do this in the least
uncomfortable way because i actually
hate talking about my own work but maybe
uh
did you learn anything from it yeah so i
didn't know much about cybersyn as being
kind of like a cybernetic system that
that was designed to try to take like
take into account the inputs and outputs
of the economy in production and
different things that they tried to
automate
the economy i didn't know the details
about that story i didn't really know
much about um
beer stafford beer the like the the
british cybernetics professor or
whatever who was brought in as a
consultant to try to design the system
so i learned uh all about that stuff and
i think there's also some
some like favorable economic numbers i
think maybe i didn't know about that
that initially when allende took rule
the economy like economic numbers were
improving
um so yeah but like otherwise i just
thought that it was uh
really like well-produced and and a
compellingly presented story um
but yeah but i would say like the whole
cyber the whole um cyber sin story
i didn't know much about that um and
yeah people i feel like
as far as i can remember talking to my
family and my cousins in chile i don't
ever recall that coming up in our
conversations about that so that was
interesting yeah it happened in a flash
right like
71-73 and then it was done
but it was the most amazing thing
to happen by the time the coup happened
cybersend i think was connected to
somewhere around uh 200 factories
which were of course state-owned that's
crazy um it kept track of a bunch of
different things including like the
inputs at the factory what was coming
out of the factory uh absentees
like for for who was working there
how often so they are keeping track of
labor numbers
and yeah the idea was that if you
have a national a national economy
shouldn't be run by a bunch of
bureaucrats
because it would be too inefficient and
also the shape of chile comes into play
here because it's extremely long i think
the longest
and thinnest country in the world so
uh they
basically had four mainframe computers
in the country and one of the computers
was uh used for this
victor did you know about allende before
or did you know oh i knew about aenda i
mean i knew the story details
and i think i said in
i think when i went on to uh pills's
stream uh we we talked a little bit
about like my own family background and
uh i mean
most of my family were actually pinochet
supporters you know i'd love to tell
some romantic story about how my parents
left
because they were like radicals and they
wanted to escape from the pinochet
regime you know i wish i could have that
story but no they just left because it
was inconvenient and the country was in
shambles but they were they were in no
danger in fact my my grandfather
was a colonel in the military but he did
retire pretty much right i think right
as allende took power so he wasn't
involved in like any of the of the mass
killings or at least so i've been told
you know maybe that's just like a a lie
but
but yeah so i knew about it my mother uh
is it was sympathetic to allende i
remember her she was like the only one
in her family the only one of her four
brothers and sisters
that was sympathetic to socialism
partially because she went to for for a
number of reasons went to a public
school didn't go to private school so
she was even though she came from a
fairly well-off family she like came
into contact with working-class people
and i think that that had an impact on
her where she believed in in in um the
socialist ideals and and was kind of
interested in marxism but yeah like when
i would go home
to chile like in my grandfather's office
i think i said this on pills stream
there's still to this day as far as i
know uh
a portrait of pinochet
uh like framed
like because he was very like he was a
supporter of the regime i mean he bought
into the idea that pinochet saved the
country from an absolute disaster and i
think i know hopefully we can get into
later in this podcast because i did do
some background some secondary reading
and i think there might be some
contestability about the extent to which
allende could have been successful with
his economy i mean i think your video
did a really good job of showing uh
you know the ways in which he was
initially successful but i i did read
some stuff that
did that seemed persuasive to me that
think that maybe it wouldn't have been
sustainable in the long term um but we
can get into that sounds exactly like
someone whose uncle owns a factory in
chile
like somebody who is schooled in chicago
it came out i know i did some background
research on you victor and you're if you
could keep talking like that i'm just
going to call you factory nephew
but let me preview though the reason why
i'm saying that because i think i i
think about um you know there's a
something that zijak talked about uh in
his movie the perverts guide to ideology
when uh which is like the the ideology
related to kind of like lost causes
and i think that there can be a
temptation like and he he uses the movie
titanic as a case in point to say that
like you know uh leonardo dicaprio
needed to die to preserve the idea of
love to preserve the ideology of love
and i think that to some extent we can
fall into like the kind of romanticism
about lost causes that it kind of
preserves trotsky is exactly the same
way so so it's like so it's like the
fact that you know this that there was
this cybernetic utopia and it got like
cut short it's like i think it
it can tempt us to think that it was or
would have been more successful than
maybe it actually had the potential to
be i mean that that is a fair point you
have an image of a of a lost future that
holds all this mystique versus maybe the
reality being just kind of like mediocre
and not very inspiring but
but i mean that's that's the problem
with the lost futures right you'll never
know
exactly of course you're 100 right i
mean i don't know if you heard the
reference but i said somewhere in there
in defense of lost causes
uh citing exactly that
and beyond that of course the
documentary is biased towards the slant
that this was visionary and ingenious
without bringing up many of the problems
that there was with it including the
bureaucracy which also didn't want to
get out of the way and another one of
the problems for example is that
factory managers just didn't see the
value in gathering all this information
and sending it in on time because
nobody knew and i mean nobody in the
world knew what a cybernetic system
could be at the time what computers
could do right this is 1970
and and to the point of lost causes
whether or not this project would have
worked if the u.s you know just decided
that they didn't want it to
we do know that cybernetic systems work
of the most
valuable corporations in the world
amazon is of course my go-to example
they do work they accomplish goals
but each of those is a profit driven
system this is the um not the only one
but one of the few examples
of a system where the designers say
we can do this and make people's lives
better rather than we can do this and
make a [ __ ] ton of money so i mean
i just want to know like why did you
decide
to explore chile like what was the
impetus behind that was this something
you've been thinking about for a long
time like did you have the allende the
chili thing
was it because you studied cybernetics
and this was sometimes an example that
was brought up in that literature
cybersin like what's the story there
yeah yeah so part of the reason i wanted
to do this episode which we'll get to uh
more in the second half is that i came
to this
with no knowledge of politics and latin
america or really any specifics about
the cia really
but cybernetics i
i know quite a lot about so i did start
it did start with what can i say about
cybernetics but as the script started
coming together i
wanted less and less this to be an
explanation about cybernetics anymore
because in this case
that's not even half the story
so it became
less about
here's what cybernetics is and more
about look at what cybernetics could
have been because
almost every other deployment of it is
either to kill people or to make money
or to kill people and to make money
and the effort
put into destroying this is just one
glimpse
of
what another use of technology could
have been so that morphed into the main
purpose
of the project i i mean i'm you can tell
the injustice of it and the conspiracy
of it
you can't explain why cybernetics always
looks nefarious without the context
around it all of why it always looks so
nefarious why it's only used for these
ends
right which was quite a monumental task
and took you
far longer than any of your other videos
right
yeah it was uh
three and a half months i guess so it's
interesting that you said
um the injustice of it outraged you
uh you know the cynical pills who
doesn't believe in political principles
and stuff it's just interesting to hear
you use such
such such language
but but you believe in justice
i don't not have political principles i
just don't think that talking about
politics
is equivalent with politics okay so you
okay okay i'm just i'm just i'm pushing
you a little bit i would also extend
like to say that making youtube videos
about politics is also not politics so
that's interesting if i'm understanding
you right when you say that that
politics talking about politics is not
the same as politics sure i certainly
agree with that but so what so do you
have a conception of the connection
between
between uh theory and praxis so like
like and i'm assuming when you say that
talking about politics is not politics
you mean that politics has to be
something that's action oriented
that's like but maybe i'm wrong uh you
know seizing control of an amazon
warehouse that would be a political
action okay right okay so okay
so so
so then but you say
talking about politics isn't the same as
politics but you know i've heard you
sometimes you know inch somewhat in
vague just
make disparaging uh humorously
disparaging comments about like the the
practice of political theory you know we
have fun mate uh
giving jabbing each other here
so
so do you think that there's no
purpose to talking about like do you
think that there's any connection
between
like wool theory well could theory help
you do a better job of taking control of
that amazon warehouse or do you just
think that those two things are
that there's no need to theorize about
taking over the amazon warehouse because
you just do it
okay well let's be clear about what this
is because we can say there's theory
then there's praxis but this is an
entertainment product it is an
educational entertainment product to be
fair but it would be preposterous for me
to say
it's something more important than that
if you want to read the book on it it's
called cybernetic revolutionaries by
eden medina which is less entertaining
but also far more informative
however it would be
silly to suggest that someone's going to
get so inspired by a youtube video that
they're gonna see is a factory that
isn't the kind of thing that gets people
to seize factories hunger for example is
a much better
impetus
for action than infotainment or theory
right
and as we're lucky enough to not be
hungry then we have time to do both ener
entertainment infotainment and theory so
if at all
the way that i see this being worthwhile
or being valuable
is that projects like this are not seen
very often because
there are very different
interests involved in the production of
most
media
almost all of the time
and i hope what people get out of it
which is why all of us are working on
the various things we are working on
is that
the world we're in
is not the only way a world could be and
if our world is this way there are
reasons for that so can a youtube video
change the world no
no period
but maybe
a lot of people who thought the world
could be changed could change it the
problem is that
one problem is that almost everything
you hear in a day is that it can't and
it won't
so this video won't do that but it could
be a drop in some future bucket allende
for his part certainly thought the world
could be changed and part of the tragedy
of this story is that no matter how much
you do right
there's a good chance you're getting
popped at the end
right right so it's a tragedy um i'm
curious so i mean maybe this is implied
but what you've said before but like if
you you know people maybe haven't seen
it yet or
are are
they they did see it already like what
when you were making it and assembling
the pieces together
were you thinking about like what you
wanted people to take away from it like
is it just like an emotion an
appreciation of it or do you want them
to think about something more deeply
like what did you have kind of an image
in your mind about what you want people
to take away from it
like with most of my
my
work
the world that you live in the world
that you're told you live in
isn't the only possible
world
so maybe it would maybe it could inspire
politics i think that's putting far too
much uh
it's far too much of a burden of action
onto a youtube video but maybe it could
inspire politics if more documentaries
were like this instead of
made by prageru
or prageru
then
this is the
this is the pendulum swinging back the
other way
fair and balanced
i want to ask a follow-up question
actually about what happened after uh
the coup because one of like the
formative political experiences for me
in fact one of the first things i could
ever remember my parents being angry
about was actually 1998 when pinochet
actually almost went to trial um in
spain and then london uh it was gonna be
a watershed moment actually an
international law as well because it was
going to be one of the first times where
a former head of state was put on trial
for crimes that he committed against his
people it didn't end up happening
because mark thatcher called some people
and he got off and he lived the rest of
his days in relative peace but
what do you think
the answer to the kind of crimes
committed about
like towards the chilean people should
have been uh because one of the big
disputes around should we put pinochet
on trial should we put his lackeys on
trial
was look this has happened it was a
tragedy it's done it's over now
nothing we can do can bring these people
back so it's time to just move on and
allow ourselves to heal whereas other
people said no
healing means that the people who did
this need to be made accountable to that
and if we are not made accountable for
that
we cannot actually move on and i think
you see these kinds of dilemmas emerging
even to this day right now uh when
they're trying to change the neoliberal
constitution and some of the defenders
will say you're still just responding to
1973
and you're unwilling to let that go and
other people say no we're trying to
finally recover from 1973 and inaugurate
a new era in the country
was that a question
yeah i'm asking you what do you think
the right attitude is to take towards
this like do you just let things go
and say you know that i would never
speculate on what the right attitude
towards that is
like totally true and what's the right
punishment for pinochet i mean he hired
we could we could even talk about
operation condor a little bit here the
[ __ ] rat lines like if you are
funding the guy
that hires nazis and i don't mean that
rhetorically he hired nazis to run his
prison camps because they were you know
that's that's their skill set that's on
their cv
so if you're funding the guy
and shaking hands with him and kissing
his ass like kissinger
did
then i think you're probably on the
wrong side of history there and pinochet
i don't know if people know this i don't
know if you guys know this but he he
[ __ ] killed people in the united
states
there's a car bomb a
a car bomb blew up in washington dc of
the leader of opposition and exile that
he just [ __ ] assassinated and they
still just kept giving him money
so
like the and the american propaganda
about this you see nixon come on tv and
he goes we are a fair and good country
we're the greatest country in the world
we've done so much for the betterment of
mankind
like just hold up a [ __ ] mirror to
your face you're the devil
yeah yeah
yeah that's the economy story that he
killed like uh orlando light earlier
yeah
i wanted to ask a question and i'm sorry
if i'm gonna be a little bit harsh but i
think this is something that you tried
to push the conversation before but you
said like okay um
june i guess you noticed by doing this
documentary and i'm not by doing this
documentary i guess the whole
documentary builds on the fact how
like the us interventionism in latin
america you mentioned operation condor
and you probably mentioned also
like the school of the americas who was
basically the cia and the u.s military
training like the military in latin
america to basically disappear people
and in all these techniques to
kind of of social control but my
question is like
how
like like when you perceive like you
proceed you're critical of this
interventionism but
like
how would you situate your role as
a white dude
coming from a canadian university
you know that's making an educational
video
on
a
region that's kind of very foreign to
your experience
like cybernetics like the site like the
whole project might not be foreign to
you but like you know like i
i don't know i'm just curious about how
you understand your role in this and as
this kind of
educational
video maker you know
damn varian coming out with the big guns
good though
i think it's personally our job to save
everyone
good uh
i'd be lying if i said i hadn't thought
about it so
can i make a video about a context in
which i have no first-hand experience
yes
but should i make a video about a
context which i have no first-hand
experience
well that's a different question so i
have settled on an answer which i hope
is a good one
which is that yes first-hand experience
is
one form of information
sometimes the way it's talked about it
sounds like
people think it's the only valid form of
information like you can only talk about
what you've experienced directly no one
thinks that anymore which i don't mean
to sound defensive but as you said
canadian
academic person making a video about
somewhere he's never been an event for
which he was not alive
um but there are other forms of
information besides first-hand
experience that i think are also valid
uh
research read a bunch of books
committee reports uh even read
uh economic articles on jstor so
i i guess i just have to hope that
that's
good enough i don't
i don't think
that anyone who does anything historical
has to have
like a personal
connection
to it but i also hope at least in this
case that i didn't ride roughshod over
the context
um
a lot of that is done using visuals
the interviews in the documentary the
speeches in the documentary
it's it's not
my voice saying this is what it's like
and it couldn't be because i wasn't
there but it's
my voice saying something like here are
numbers here are photos here's nixon's
perspective on it here's ayende's
perspective on it
and
if i were chilean it would have turned
into a
different project if i were alive it
would have turned out differently if i
were a conservative economist it would
have turned out differently
so i could never
would never suggest that it's without
bias
and probably blindness to certain
nuances
um but if those biases preclude my
saying anything about it at all well i'm
i'm not convinced of that though i'm
sure victor's family will hate it
i'll let you know what my family thinks
of it when it comes out publicly i'll
i'll i'll pass that feedback on along to
you all my all my right-wing neo-liberal
family members are probably gonna
[ __ ] hate it
your comment there reminded me of meme i
saw not too long ago when like uh falcon
and the winter soldier was coming out
which is like how america perceives
itself and it was captain america you
know the chris evans uh one and it's
like how the rest of the world sees
america and it was just like the red
skull grabbing on to the brick being
like i [ __ ] dominate all yeah i did
want to quickly ask though about the
about the the cybersyn system and
because i think there was one ambiguity
i was left with after watching the video
just
like i mean i got in principle that it
was taking in inputs and outputs from
the from the factories but i'm kind of
curious like
was the purpose of the cybersyn system
ultimately to to just have an automated
command economy or would there still be
an economy that was responding to supply
and demand and that there would still be
some sort of like
market activity because i guess i wasn't
sure like i don't yeah i don't even know
for sure if allende was actually trying
to eliminate
private property and eliminate market
exchange like free market exchange and
just have it all be like kind of
automated cybernetic system or and this
cybernetic system would sort of assist
in a kind of
more limited free market exchange or
would market exchange be totally
replaced by the cybernetic system
um well the cybernetic system there was
there would be still pro private
property he
made no intention to abolish that
um his main concern was that the
production of chilean resources and then
consumer goods that the government owned
specifically that was to be connected to
the cybersyn system right so they're
buying all american cars and american
television sets with the raw materials
that are coming out of
the mountains in chile
um and he just said why don't we have
a chilean car company why don't we have
a chilean television company um because
then you just yeah you're basically
cutting out the middlemen so there would
are there the it wouldn't really affect
the consumer side i think that he saw
even if the government had
um
you know started their electronics
company or their car company that would
compete
with the other goods right but the idea
would be that it would be cheaper and
affordable to ayande's base which are
the poorer people
and they would be able to afford those
at the time luxury goods that only the
politically connected were able to have
access to
right right okay uh that and it's it's
worth mentioning too that so he did so
pinochet um when he took over and he had
the chicago boys come and advise him on
how to restart this sort of like
free-market chilean neo-liberal economy
dude when they call that [ __ ] the
chilean miracle it is
it is
milton's
miracle of chile because
by 1972 apparently chile's inflation
rate was at 150 percent
and during the 1980s
it
supposedly turned around
yes
the inflation was
very high and that was partially because
allende raised the wages of workers so
they had money
but it was caused in
the most part because there was a
blockade on all products entering yeah
it was exacerbated by the us so that was
exacerbated by the us but there's but
but there's a good two like i mean
most economists
from what i read though most economists
were like allende probably did raise
wages a little bit too quickly because
it did it did accelerate inflation to a
point where like the purchasing power of
that those raised wages started to
become
worse and then of course it was
exacerbated by
by uh by blockades but i did just want
to say like the irony of when pinochet
took over and he was like going to
privatize all the industries again he
was like well the one thing that i'm not
going to privatize is the copper mines
so they and all the economists agree
they're like actually it's probably a
good idea for for chile to to keep those
nationalized copper mines which is kind
of amusing because um
you know i think that probably uh a lot
of american companies were pissed at
that because like there was a lot of
american interest in the copper mines
but i think even the chicago boys like
the milton friedmans and stuff were like
economically you actually should hang on
to those mines and keep them
nationalized um yeah that wasn't that
wasn't one of his radical policies even
um the centrist that he was running
against
he
also wanted to
uh privatize the copper mines so or
public or you mean take control oh yeah
sorry for uh bring them under government
control
right okay
nationalize
well
in case you didn't know last year
actually
they finally repealed the pinochet era
constitution
that actually happened last year in
october
uh they celebrated the um somebody
somebody's quoted as saying we've been
living under an illegitimate
constitution created by a military
regime that only allowed progress for
those who had money
there's been very few times that chilean
people had shared a collective victory
like today this is this is from the
guardian
so they they actually repealed those
pinochet era
which is odd because milton freeman
in
an interview
says
you know in the end the chilean economy
did very well more importantly in the
end the central government the military
junta was replaced by a democratic
society at first it was
leaning towards a communist regime and
then the military took over which is a
top-down regime and then magically this
is part of the miracle right the uh the
free market economy
succeeded
and then whenever whenever you hear the
word free market economy it means
everything's privatized that's what it
means to friedman and the chicago boys
yeah with the chicago boys there was
something like 600 state-owned companies
which were you know in fact not just the
mines but factories and all that after
the chicago boys there was like eight
they sold the utility companies sold the
uh
communications telephone networks they
just sold all of it yeah they privatize
everything and the way friedman tells it
is that in the in this interview he does
in 2000 the way friedman tells it is
that the communist regime which is like
a bottom-up regime i don't know what
else the [ __ ] socialism is it got
replaced by a military junta top down
regime and then due to their efforts
this military regime
was replaced by a democratic free market
regime but then the way that people are
framing this actual repeal of pinochet
era
constitutions
is that
all of this is continuous like the
milton freeman and the pinochet regime
change was actually a continuous thing
it wasn't you know military junta and
then it turns around when the chicago
boys come in like that was all a [ __ ]
continuous
thing and when you hear about this
miracle of chile where you know they
were in danger of
going into hyperinflation like it was
all part of the same that's all p's in
the same [ __ ] pod everybody's
experiencing the this wealth gap being
opened up
yeah it's hard to say i mean i'm i i
agree that i mean i think one of the
most astounding things in my opinion
about the whole story is that he was
democratically elected he wanted to keep
the basic structure of the rule of law
as written he didn't he didn't want to
and this i think your video does a great
job of of explaining all this
um he didn't you know he didn't want to
like like in cuba or the soviet union
make like a
command economy and like vanquish all of
his uh his um you know he tried to play
fair right he tried to play within the
framework and he got castro called him
an idiot
yeah for doing that right but but but
there is an interesting thing like i
think that it's definitely up for debate
how well he would have actually
succeeded how had he been allowed to to
proceed like i think that there's
i did a bit of reading like i think
there's maybe the inflation would have
actually been quite a problem even
without the blockades because i think he
probably was raising wages a little bit
too quickly for the economy to handle if
he was gonna keep things
the way they were but um
definitely
still
uh an astounding
expression of injustice uh but we see
and this is the main kind of the main
point of the documentary is we see
cybernetic systems work amazon [ __ ]
works great
except that it has except that keeps the
exploitation so this was meant to be and
it could have been a cybernetic
system
that made a functional government
um and that ran a nationalized economy
instead of a
completely privatized economy is there
any is there any examples of like more
cybernetic governments in in right now
that like in this the soviet union could
have and they had some experiments in
that direction but their bureaucracy was
so bloated and there were so many like
you know those yeah the communication
wasn't there people wanted to keep the
piece of the pie that they had so the
soviet union could have done it but they
were too uh
they were chewing it for themselves
we've got a cybernetic free market not a
cybernetic government system
big data right this this this whole
thing is kind of like a story of big
data as well and you like you have the
chile big data
in use for the benefit of the nation and
the people and today we have you know
big data in use for private profit and
you know corporations
and for and for making profiting off of
the biochemical drama of our children's
minds
uh with with the with their phones to
quote to quote uh bill bo burnham from
his from his from his special one of the
interesting things about
cyber capitalism and there's a lot of
good marxist theorists doing uh about
this is that there was actually this
utopian neoliberal moment in the early
2000s where people were commenting on
how we were past the period of crises uh
and business cycles because digital
technology would be allow
capitalists to predict so accurately the
way the economy was going uh that they
would be able to make strong investments
and they'd be able to finance uh
properly uh and then
2008 happens uh and there's this
gigantic
leap of faith uh that people take uh
saying no we still should put our
convictions uh in this direction because
all that we need to do is devise better
digital technologies uh and then the
system won't be prone to these kind of
crises
my friend my friend uh
works in like
uh basically like trying to automate the
bureaucracy of canada like that's his
job in the government and uh he was
actually telling me that although it's
not quite the same as the type of
cybernetic system you're talking about
but he was telling me that like the most
kind of like integrated well integrated
into like uh the web and just like
networks government bureaucracy is
actually estonia they're like uh like
everything is very streamlined in
estonia like so for example the one
example of gaming is like when you're
born
it's like uh you're you don't even need
to sign up for anything so like as
parents like i think automatically like
this the system will see oh you have a
child and then they'll automatically
sign you up for all the tax benefits
uh the like the the the birth
certificate like all these things are
integrated so like the systems know
when one thing is inputted to adjust
everything else for that couple
automatically and everything runs in the
background it's kind of cool
yeah like if you watch the video
you understand that like the the
cybernetic aspect is meant to get to the
problems quicker right so it's mentioned
for instance that
like with the cybernetics system in
place right they can get to disruptions
in the supply line in the production
before they disrupt the supply line
whereas today's governments get
information about the way the market is
going maybe i don't know what the number
is today two four six months after the
actual event has occurred they get the
information about it so they're acting
way after the fact what the cybernetic
thing is supposed to do is you know
one yeah take out the bureaucratic
inefficiency and to help them
react to the problem quicker by getting
real-time information about from all
these different sources but here's
here's an interesting quote by milton
freeman this is really funny to listen
to after watching this video you should
watch this video then recall this quote
milton freeman quote two thousand nixon
was the most socialist pr of the
presidents of the united states in the
20th century that's what he said
and the interviewer says i've heard
nixon accused of being many things but
never as a socialist
he says well well his ideas weren't
socialists but quite the opposite but if
you look at what happened during his
administration first of all the number
of pages in the federal register like he
goes on to make this [ __ ] like i
don't even think it's a walk back he's
just doubling down something about the
environmental protection agency yeah he
created it nixon is the most socialist
of presidents
so this is the most socialist president
of the united states he was too
socialist for allende i think he's like
you you think you can do socialism by
ending nixon's like i can do [ __ ]
socialism here we go hold my beer and
then he did it
yeah one the one
emphasis or the one stress i want to put
on all of this is like cybernetics
we always say technology is not neutral
but cybernetics can do some really evil
[ __ ]
so it's not like i'm saying cyber not
something you're not some techno utopian
yeah i'm not i am certainly not a techno
utopian but
the point of a cybernetic system like
according to systems theory is like
the the goals that you give something
are going to
bring about its outcome and so far all
of our cyber cybernetic systems except
this one experiment
are capitalist pretty much and this was
the one uh the one lost future of
something that could have been different
yeah it would be a real big mistake to
look at this sort of technological
apparatus as neutral it would be a very
big mistake
it definitely you know draws the bow
pretty tight but whether it's going to
shoot left or right depends on how it's
used in the end
but it's certainly far from just a
neutral
sort of thing we can project our desires
in our future utopias onto right
okay so on that concluding point uh you
can watch it on the 18th publicly but it
is pre-released for patrons already
yeah i'm hoping it does well because
well i sunk about 500 hours into it and
that is frankly a very stupid thing to
do
if you are a servant to the
dark algorithmic gods but as we alluded
to before
the world has not changed all that much
victor said something interesting way
back during your family biography that
your mom
was less hostile to allende because she
went to public school as opposed to
private school so on that note i
wondered if marian you taught at a
private school could you elucidate
some of the way that class works at
least in the mexican context and how
that's reflected in the education system
oh there is i've uh
i've met people from around the region i
got
i have friends living in paraguay i've
traveled to brazil
and i have friends
from back today like living in colombia
and argentina and elsewhere and i think
um
some of the experiences are very similar
where it's not only like well of course
there's a class i mentioned like
um
people will try to favor if they can't
sending their kids to
like um private school right even since
elementary school even sometimes even
before that right uh
it also gives you a lot of advantages
because if you go to private school you
are more likely to
learn a second language very well and
for some people it's not even a second
language it's a third language so of
course that since you're very little
that already is like expands your
opportunities of course that puts you in
a better position to go to university
like i went to a private high school and
even my friends
that couldn't afford to go to a private
university they
guarantee their
kind of their spot in the national
public university right so you of course
receive a better education and
i guess
because there are so many things to say
but i i guess one of the things is um
private universities in mexico
are very class oriented right there
there's this whole mentality in which oh
no like
like from the inside and from the
outside right like uh at least the
university i went to like there's um
there's a lot of people that receive
scholarships i also was a scholarship
recipient right so it's not like oh i'm
on like i'm i'm on the like reach side
my parents can afford this right but
even like the people that receive a
scholarship like they develop i think
this mentality like oh like some sort of
like
i deserve this right i work hard and
this is not to say i work hard through
university right it's like hard enough
that like well you have to read exams et
cetera it's not to say that people don't
work hard but i think that like there's
this very like i don't know like
mentality
that oh no like you are gonna be the
entrepreneurials you are the ones that
know you are gonna be the class at least
this country right and even if it's not
out of us overtly expressed there are so
many things that kind of develop this
sense this this kind of ideas and people
not to say the majority i also had a lot
of classmates that were very left-wing
like left-wing as i was which was nice
right to to have like this some sort of
like i guess solidarity but i also seen
the same happening in uh like in other
countries as i said with my friends in
in colombia and argentina where of
course like people that go to private
schools are also more likely to work for
foreign companies like to have better
opportunities like one of the things i
remember people will tell us in
university will be like oh well just
because you are graduating for this
university your cvs like when you are
applying for a job like recruiters will
look at your like cvs first then they
will look at other universities right so
it not only creates these weird
individuals that i don't like right that
they have this sense of entitlement but
they also has played a huge role i think
recently in the kind of um
in the polarization at least of my own
country between like the the president
we have now who is
who campaign as a leftist i have my
doubts but the whole point his whole
point was to fuel the anger against like
the
upper middle class and the middle class
right as like all these people that have
this sense of entitlement i'm not saying
they don't a lot of them do but and i
feel that maybe a similar thing was what
happened in brazil with bolsonaro you
know like like the rich versus the poor
kind of thing that like happens a lot of
time i also seen it in colombia like uh
now that there was a protest right like
huge protest uh earlier during the year
and last year
sadly like the upper middle class
friends that i have like their way of
resolving the issues is like oh let's
just not fight right when like people
that come from poor backgrounds it's
like well no there are so many deep
issues here
and even if they don't receive like a
formal training education they recognize
them because they lift them right so i
think that sometimes private education
insulates you
from
some of the things going on in the world
that you don't get unless you go to i
don't know to public school
like you are in touch also for people
from with people from a more working
class background or like from other
paths in life right
yeah i just want to give one anecdotal
story that i i did think was really
funny but it expresses these kind of
divisions very nicely so when i was
teaching at techno monterey very very
advanced private school costs a lot of
money
but it competes regularly with the major
public university there unam uh which
will offer major bursaries for students
to come but not enough to live
particularly well you'll basically have
enough to go to school live in a very
shitty apartment and feed yourself
that's it so to celebrate the birthday
of our university we partnered with
starbucks to create a very special
frappuccino with the school colors
and somebody at the public university
took issue with that and a bunch of our
students ended up sending out tweets and
instagram photos drinking the starbucks
frappuccino and bragging about how much
money they had and how many of these
they were going to have over the course
of the day and it created a huge uproar
with people attacking the school saying
this goes to show you how open to these
people are they won't even drink mexican
coffee and then you know our school
fired back by being like well this is
how cutting edge and american we are it
was a huge mess where there was this
weird intersection of is about class um
latin american status um
social prestige oliver kind of getting
mired in to the debate around this
frappuccino
so my next question uh i guess we have
three political theorists here
but one thing that i hear often uh said
in chat rooms and
and things like that is
the there is a vibrant left in latin
america
and i wondered if you could explain
or any one of you actually elaborate on
the extent to which that's true and how
it compares with a country like ours
which
i don't know if you could really say
that there's a left here an actively
political left
well it's true that nominally it seems
like latin american countries have a
more activist
left that has taken power like nominally
in the sense that they're labeled and
they make these promises but they've
also been
a lot less stable and a lot less
successful at implementing like
meaningful uh change and there's a lot
of reasons for that a lot of them have
to do with like the
i'm sure the influence of
the united states and neoliberalism but
i think there's also like a more
fundamental problem that maybe we'll
talk about uh that i think just has to
do with
sort of like the the role of
institutions how well how well they're
trusted because i mean the moment that
you don't trust
uh an institution as a society it means
that any changes that try to funnel
through those institutions
are much much more difficult to
accomplish
um but i don't know i mean i don't know
that the concrete
marion would probably know more about
the actual political parties at least in
mexico i'm sure which i would know like
pretty much nothing about i know a
little bit about chile but yeah i think
uh latin america has a very rich history
in terms of like uh
like
leftist movements and thought uh i
actually one of my favorite spots in
mexico city is by the history museum
which is the castle which has been it
was to build for the viceroy by viceroy
i guess uh and eventually the
viceroyalty ended so
uh it became a building that was given
many uses but there's a
a mural there a painting that has like
basically depicts like the history like
a mexican revolution where like the the
revolution was
largely started by the
nation bush rossi that was like unhappy
that they were not politically
represented but it
rapidly turned into like a national
movement and eventually you had like the
peasants rising and the
mural is a picture of the peasants and
then marks at the beginning of them
right kind of marching and giving them
the red book right so it's like very
very
like uh i don't know i guess symbolic
but uh what i was gonna say
is like i didn't know that that it was
like that famous in leftist circles
until i went to london and you will see
like someone like slavojic using it as
an example and a lot of leftists that i
talked that are from europe and they
knew about it they also knew foreign for
example about the zapatistas in mexico
they fight against the state so i didn't
i had no idea that these movements were
like had so much international prestige
for what they were but um what i want to
say is like yes there has like you have
to understand that latin america is a
continent that after they like after the
their different countries gain
independence they also have they had to
fight other other sorry forms of
uh colonialism right france tried to
have their share of the continent
england tried to fight the share of the
continent so there was always this kind
of opposition towards colonialism for
example for the whole like 19th century
was like try to like fence this power
off and also try to oppose like the
liberal tradition is a strong tradition
in mexico and the continent because it
was a way of fighting off in like
european imperialism
uh and then during the 20th century you
have like the for the second half you
have the cold war also you have the
beginning of the century like the
russian revolution and a lot of
movements that were inspired by the by
the russian revolution and that thought
that something like that could be done
in the continent uh and then with the
rise and the consolidation of american
like a germanic power
and the more of course pretentious like
the u.s got
about the region being basically their
backyard the more you saw the rise of uh
guerillas
it was not only like um
political parties but it was seems like
there was no opportunity to form
political parties like uh as you
mentioned with chile chile after the
coup they
had a a military junta like ruling in
mexico there was an asia munich party so
and and that's a history of most of the
subcontinent and and of mexico so there
was really not much opportunity to
create a party more like so this was
expressed in in the form of guerrillas
like chile are their own guerrillas
mexico so mexico was um all the south of
mexico has a history during the 20th
century of yours leftist guerrillas that
were
also
that were looking towards cuba for
supporting or they never really got it
in that respect but and they also looked
to the ussr right elsewhere to try to
form like international bonds i guess
today what you're seeing
is again like uh like a lot of
resurgence of like leftist movements one
of the strongest movements today in the
region i will say is a feminist movement
it has created like regional and
international ties that i don't think
like i think few movements manage to
create before them at least in latin
america right like like
there was this group of women called uh
las tesses who created like they are
from chile i actually think and they
created a feminist anthem that was sunk
everywhere from like latin america to
russia like this is not to say there has
been a feminist movement like in mexico
latin america for like decades but until
very recently they managed to like
have more support and also create more
international like uh links that i don't
think i've seen like i think it's a
dream of some of the you know like your
socialist brows in the region it was a
dream that they never succeeded like the
women like started to do it until very
recently which i think is
um
yeah like somehow unexpected uh
uh in the sense not that they couldn't
but that people didn't thought it was
going to be them i think leading the
the left today
i tend to agree with john steinbach that
one of the reasons why socialism never
took root in the united states and i
would add canada and maybe even the uk
to that list as americans and canadians
don't like to see themselves as poor or
exploited they like to see themselves as
temporarily embarrassed millionaires
right there's this kind of insistence on
a middle-class kind of attitude that
really isn't present in my experience in
the region people are much more
cognizant of the fact that society's
divided into rich and poor uh that
people who are at the top have a lot
more power and influence and those at
the bottom have far less and there's all
kinds of foreign exploitation associated
with that and it's not hard to figure
out why that would be if you look at the
history of the region and the
extraordinary classism that emerged with
the spanish colonial system and that
persisted down to this day
which is often associated with like very
vehement degrees of racism as well
the second thing that i think a lot of
people underestimate when it comes to
how why is there such a vibrant left in
latin america and this is especially
true of western leftists uh is the
importance of religion uh
and the way that many people are able to
mobilize major religious texts in the
region uh for radical causes if you
think about the emergence of something
like liberation theology very
influential particularly in south
america and it was essentially an
attempt to combine marxism with
christianity which very few people
elsewhere in the world have thought to
do and it was a very appealing mixture
right since it's allowed people to
basically hold to conventional or
traditional religious values but
reappropriate them in anti-capitalist
ways uh it's worth noting you know one
of the founders of the mexican
revolution uh jose morelos uh was a
priest right he's the one who kind of
led the revolt uh against this
exploitative system right
no it was miguel
thank you yeah sorry i i got the two
confused excuse me uh the last thing i
think that's also really important is
that um
starting especially in the 1950s and
this is being more modern there was a
really anti-colonial uh quality to
socialism that made it very appealing to
many people in the region who were
determined to resist american
imperialism uh and i think that this
actually isn't unique to latin america
you also saw it in places like
sub-saharan africa and their kind of own
anti-colonial efforts against the
british uh of course they kind of
mobilized it in a lot of different ways
uh that were pretty unique to them but
like marian said i think that you're
really seeing a resurgence of something
anti-colonial
independence-minded spirit and some of
the more successful leftist movements
that have emerged in the reason whether
you're thinking about like the workers
party in brazil
the movement for socialism uh in bolivia
which i think people should talk more
about
or even amlo
in mexico although i have
issues with that so those are the three
reasons i think that there's been a lot
more strength for the left on the ground
in latin america
than there has been elsewhere yeah it's
interesting because
when i visit my family i'll like tell
them that you know i'm on the left and i
think it's interesting that they have i
think because of the
well sort of the observation i kind of
made was like it seems like at least in
chile there's not really like um
uh i think they feel that there's no
like
what what can be perceived as like you
know by centrists as like a reasonable
left-leaning party like in their mind
it's either like we're within like the
full-out neolibs
or or with these people who we think
might be crazy and are going to do like
insane things
so like it kind of whereas like i'm just
like well in the left in north america
and europe is like
i mean there's a left that's nascent but
there's also like a lot of more
center-left parties that give
that kind of offer an option i think uh
they so that's the at least my read from
my family that because i'll tell them
i'm like i always vote left
and they're just like what they're like
but i'm just like it's different in
canada like like you you'd vote for them
too probably if you lived in canada yeah
i also think that what's perceived left
in latin america in comparison to what's
perceived like left in canada like i
don't know it's interesting to me that
something that people that are centrists
might accept like
like
they will not necessarily maybe
perceive them as
left
or are willing to accept them because
maybe they think is left but just
because it benefits them they'll they'll
accept them that's not the case in latin
america i think or at least in mexico
people will like if it has a left
association it will be like oh no even
if it benefits them i think you know
like uh
for example like social security like
when when that was established in mexico
it was like a very good system that got
like
like overwhelm over the years like the
past the population grew then the
governments like start to undermine it
to try to privatize it so now it's a
mess and i think one of the things that
the feminist has to recognize at least
in my country in mexico is that they are
gonna push outside of the political
parties kind of like as women's
organizations from like ngos and like
from the local congresses to make the
changes needed so it's a way to bypass
this problem of the left being unable to
do something what they have
done is rely heavily on the support of
the citizenship of the citizenry and
also to go to the local congresses
instead of the like you know the
national congress is to try to actually
operate some form of change
uh and like and i have to say that they
have managed to accomplish like
important things like typifying um
you know i don't know like uh like
the term in english but it's like when
you share your private photos with
someone now that is a crime in mexico
like if if you reshare those now in
mexico you can go to yale
and they did it like they managed to do
it like again
pushing from outside the
like
the the normal thing would be okay like
let's have a political party support
this etc right but i think it speaks
directly to what you were saying like
that
like it is true that some people
perceive in latin america that the life
doesn't work and that they don't have a
program
because they
like
i don't know there's all sorts of
problems there but i think um
like to a certain degree is true right
and i think you can see something
interesting happening in latin america
also with things like bulsa familia uh
introduced by the workers party in
brazil under the lula administration
because what's interesting is despite
being like a far right demagogue bolton
arrows tried to roll back some of the
lula administration welfare reformed and
he hasn't been able to do so because
they're ubiquitously popular including
with a large part of his socially
conservative but economically moderate
base right
and they're popular because they work i
mean brazil's poverty rate went down
from 12 to seven percent over the lulu
administration so you can't really
retract these kind of things without
creating a big uproar uh so i think what
this really just proves is the left
needs to create institutions that people
like
and they like them because they work you
know at least for the people that
they're intended to help right and i
think that one of the problems is that
we don't always
do that very successfully if we focus
too much on
big structural and ideological changes
rather than things like famine relief
providing health care you know making
sure that kids people families with
children make sure their kids are taken
out looked after that kind of stuff so
we like our political theory here we
like
debating the basis of power and you know
the ideal grounds of democracy but the
left there is not only trying to win
elections but also trying to compete
with foreign corporate interests so
we've talked at length about american
intervention in chile
but before we get on our high horse
which for canadians is like well at
least we're not them
but our mining corporations are equally
as evil and in countries like el
salvador
guatemala mexico several times a year
union activists trying to organize
workers are threatened or they just
disappear
so lest we excuse ourselves uh we're
implicated and miriam said it earlier
but the quote is that
this is
this is our backyard and what's your
backyard
well you don't live there you just store
your [ __ ] there until you need it and
then go there once in a while to relax
on a deck chair so
i don't know not not like we can do much
we can theorize politics online or in
books but
there's no
there's no ahead of the snake
just in case you want to sue a canadian
mining company and you're a foreign
national as of 2019 supreme court ruling
you can uh so if you're an air trader in
latin america and you want to come to
canada to soothe the ass off one of our
mining companies in our supreme court i
strongly endorse you doing so and if you
are in toronto while doing it and you
come to my house i will personally buy
you a beer and toast to your success and
you couldn't do this before 2019 you
just couldn't sue a company
it's very hard to fault to sue um a
private company in the host country of
that company there's a huge amount of
entanglements that ensue so the supreme
court did actually try to make it easier
in part because canadian mining
companies were getting such a bad
reputation for exactly all the things
you were describing like just going and
killing people wiping out you know uh
you know union leaders all the stuff
that canada wants to be known for all
right so how do we do
political theory
in an environment like that
well i think that part of the problem
with political theories well actually i
mean i think that part of the problem
with leftist egalitarian emancipatory
political theory is actually that it
doesn't take those things into account
or it does take them into account but
kind of in like the wrong way i think
sometimes it's kind of what my
dissertation's about it's like i think
that it takes these things as being
like so monolithic these these these
forces which they are in a sense
um that like the that it kind of like
hedges towards well that means the only
thing that we can do is like revolution
violent overthrow violent revolution
because like these forces are so strong
and i think that like
i think that political theory needs to
do the work to be like well how can you
work
um how like how do you keep your eyes on
at least left-wing political theory on
just like making people's lives better
within those systems within those
constraints within within the things
that actually like
taking into account the barriers to
change the barriers to action
um i think that that has to be included
uh in political theorization
not just as something that needs to be
like destroyed or revolutionized against
yeah i would agree with victor that uh
sadly
the western canon
like the like the canon itself i'm not
saying like um
there are no people critical to it but
like it like fails to give answers there
um
in the sense that it usually treats
these issues as
not relevant or like accidents or um
like um
doesn't even treat sometimes like uh the
problems for example with race right or
with colonialism um
and this is very aware when you take any
class on political theory right on the
history and then when you come to kent
and people like matthew who like hand
will tell you all but he was not that
racist right there's a people that tell
you no he was a racist writer or when
you tried to like or would you look at
lock and yeah he might be this
egalitarian but then he has some
problematic things when it comes to race
right so i think this is all just to say
that uh like it like
yeah like western political theory i
think like i will say aside from marx
who kind of
saw that this had kind of a global and
geographical dimension to it that was
important to highlight i will say that
other like most of the theories like
fall short on trying to understand this
and i
like in latin america i think there has
been a huge recognition of that of this
issue because there has been a huge push
towards what's called uh epistemologists
of the south which is kind of a colony
say the decolonization of your thought
first right like and this place in all
aspects not only in
epistemology but it also like there are
some feminists that for example say why
are we fighting about this whole
feminist category for example with the
trans when like the whole cathedral of
woman sorry why are we fighting these
like gender categories or excuse me
like when the whole impos like the whole
idea of being a woman was for example an
imposition from the west that was so
different from the idea of what being a
woman was for a lot of people in the
global south like for example africa or
like latin america right
or like it has to do for example with
that but in political theory it also has
to do with like well let's try to
find the theories that actually help us
like
understand and process our own reality
in like kind of highlighting these terms
kind of
like this is a region that ha during the
20th century had to fight not only
against its own
like uh antagonisms and problems but
also with like a foreign intervention
like the sorry for the intervention from
the u.s
where i think
this has been sometimes overly used as
an excuse from the left to try and of
justify their own failures and it also
plays as say um
it played a major role in the rhetoric
of someone like chavez and maduro to
kind of
get by with their authoritarianism
right so
and i think sometimes this also plays a
role when it comes to theory because
people are like i and and this has
happened to me here too when you talk to
people that are like
critical of like the canon in political
theory for example but also like in a
lot of the humanities and social
sciences like
because you want to be so critical but
because they want to be so critical of
like from these impositions they are
willing to kind of ditch them and also
ditch the good that can come from them
you know and it's like well what's the
point of having all this history of
thought
where like kind of some of it has
actually advanced some interesting
positions when you're gonna just say
well it doesn't work
let's get
away with it right it's like
well but like what about i don't know
like to me it seems kind of
naive it seems like that's not the way
to go to just say like well this is
knowledge that has been imposed to us
and that's it like think of all the
times of corona okay so seeing science
in western sciences and in position
let's not get vaccinated let's not get
that advice from doctors you know you
are very like you're one step away from
this kind of type of like
like no like kind of
opinions that i don't know i get
uncomfortable with so i do think that
there's some interesting things that
come from recognizing this kind of
[Music]
imperialistic practices that have deeply
damaged
like the region they take the lives of a
lot of environmental activists as you
mentioned and canada
in mexico at least uh
supports the criminal organizations to
kind of get rid of the environmentalists
so they can um
kind of have access to the land right so
of course you have to like denounce that
but then there's this boundary that
people are willing to go and this is
where the public university in mexico at
least plays a role it also fuels a lot
of like
anger against everything that's foreign
and it has also come uh all sadly our
president today in mexico is like that
he defunded all scholarships for you to
go study abroad because no like
like why do you want to go abroad like
that's wrong like stay in mexico right
kind of like
like curtails like for example me as a
political theory is like i do like
western political theory that's what i
like to do it's like oh no stay in
mexico and do what i want you to do it's
like it's some sort of like to me it's
like i don't know
in a way it's also curtailing like as a
leftist governor as it's it's supposed
to be like it is just ending your kind
of
the possibility of you pursuing your
individual like
aspirations yeah so i don't know i
there's some positive thought what i
want to say is of course there there are
so many also things that have to be done
but for example what i've seen in mexico
is like a lot of people like
are of course furious at the mexican
companies sorry other canadian companies
but they do not do anything else for
example they do not pressure the mexican
government so they develop mechanisms so
you can sue a canadian company in
mexican soil you know like think about
like this like you mentioned mad well
they can sue
canadian companies here this is people
that don't have the money to even leave
their communities you know they do this
because it's their survival so that it's
not like they have access to lawyers and
they don't know the languages like oh
like like
it's not that they're the resource like
their legal resource might be there but
it's just a formalism i think for the
government to say oh we're doing
something when you're actually not doing
enough because how is this person in
fact so the company so i think but like
in mexico as i said like oh no canadian
mining companies are the devil and they
are but there is nothing much done to
kind of actually do something you know
um in the last elections people didn't
in didn't even in these regions with the
canadian mining companies sometimes it
they didn't even voted for candidates
that
had a kind of like
an agenda that included i don't know
some uh environmental issues so i think
there are like
a lot of problems in there
the kind of thing that i think is
problematic when it comes to applying
anglo-american political theory to the
region is twofold right one is that a
lot of anglo-american political theory
is attracted to what's sometimes called
transcendental institutionalism which is
basically the job of a political
theorist is to be an ideal theorist uh
tell you the kind of institutions you
should have almost invariably state
institutions uh and then say just go out
and build those you know tinker with
them a little bit for regional think
like uh context uh but more or less
that's what we want right uh and the
kind of lack of interest in theorizing
about things like power for example uh
particularly economic power but also
other forms of power uh that
you know is essential to understanding a
lot of the problems of the region just
doesn't really filter into this kind of
political theorizing all that often it's
gotten a little bit better since the
1970s or 1980s but it's still a major
problem right the other thing that i
think that's also very problematic and
it's related to this problem of
transcendental institutionalism
is that anglo-american political theory
remains very fixated on the idea of the
state and in particular this fetish for
a well-functioning state that's going to
create order allow the economy and
particularly the market economy to kind
of do its thing
and that will provide a minimal degree
of resources pretty effectively to the
population there's very little interest
in
theorizing in a context where the state
may not be capable of doing those kinds
of things even if you wanted to and
there's also very little interest in
theorizing about how it is that
international relations and geopolitics
play a major role in actually
determining what it is that the state
does and i think one of the reasons why
anglo-american and for that matter
european political theorists just aren't
that interested in this because they've
never really had to consider this
problem all that carefully for the most
part going back to the treaty of
australia there was this supposition
that sovereign independent state could
more or less do what it liked
you know
including in its colonies that's never
been the case in the latin american
region where there's always been this
concern that some imperial power is
going to come and essentially determine
how it is that your state's going to
organize this business even internally
and this is where i think marion is
correct that one of the few theater
political theorists who actually was
sensitive to this question very early on
was karl marx who was arguably the first
political theater since at least the
scholastics to take geopolitics
as seriously as he took state politics
right
pretty much everyone else uh if you
think about mutsuki lock
uh rousseau even some radical like or so
um
mill you know all of them are thinking
in a status context rather than thinking
geopolitically right so i think for
political theory to really touch on the
region it needs to give up its fixation
on transcendental institutionalism uh
and it needs to be able to recognize
that
it that it's impossible to theorize
about politics in a status context while
ignoring geopolitics completely that
represents a very privileged eurocentric
and west valley and kind of conception
of what it is that political theory is
supposed to do i think that
while i largely agree with some of that
i i do want to resist a little bit i
think that sometimes in dis in
theorizing about non-western contexts
there's like a little bit too much of an
emphasis on just trying to kind of like
blame the geopolitics or whatever to say
like oh well
you know it's it's it's all because like
there's some like the it's like blaming
it all on like the industrialized
countries which is you know i mean it's
true that that no doubt um western
countries have
have had uh um have had an impact i mean
i was going to talk about trust before
am i allowed to talk about it now or not
yet
all right victor i'll feed you the
question you've been waiting for
victor what do you think about the
suburban undergrad kids uh fetishizing
latin american movements without taking
the context into account
i know you love the
when the kids bring up the zapatistas to
you oh yeah of course i like that
question i've thought about it for a
long time they use i think that they use
that example
sometimes with undue optimism about what
it actually means and maybe don't
necessarily look into like
the empirical outcomes although i mean
yeah i don't i don't know
too too much about the zapatistas and
specifics but i've read a few articles
that it's not necessarily what it's
cracked up to be
but i do want to say that like
i think
part of the the
to me the elephant in the room when
trying to understand to theorize like
why aren't
these countries able to build sustained
movements and have like change i guess
like some sort of systematic social
institutional change that actually leads
to like concrete improvement in people's
lives and i think that like yes there's
these geopolitical factors that have an
impact and
and but i think that also there's this
question of like trust what kind of like
trust culture is there in those
societies and of course there's a lot of
reasons for why
um there might be like a lack of trust
in institutions and maybe some of those
reasons are um you know geopolitical but
i still think like ultimately um to me
one of the most interesting realms of
theorization is to like think about
um what it what to what extent do the
people in in these countries in these
contexts
have trust have a foundation of trust in
each other and in institutions because i
mean i can say at least anecdotally from
traveling to chile and i think in
talking to marion at other times she she
reported similar experiences in in
mexico
there's like there's there's this kind
of mentality in chile at least where
people always think that everyone else
is trying to [ __ ] them over
like like like everyone assumes that
everyone else is out to get them
and like i think and they think that
like that you know the government's
trying to [ __ ] them over this person's
gonna try to like screw you over like
you should cut that person off because
if you don't cut them off on the highway
you're gonna get cut off and it's just
like there's no trust
to like make space for like the good
will of other people
or at least much less
and i think that that's gonna like have
a bleeding effect on to how people
respond to to proposals to change things
like they're not going to trust those
changes and then i think people in
government too like
i think this culture of like
not having trust in institutions and in
your fellow
um
citizen ends up having this deleterious
effect where even politicians it also
has a self-reinforcing effect where
they're
because they think everyone else is
trying to skim off the top i better skim
off the top two because other people are
going to skim off the top of i don't
and it's like and somehow there's
something that happened in westernized
countries
where uh well or industrialized
countries because in all western
countries the in fact i was looking at
the empirical
research on trust and government polls
and it's actually all asian countries
that have the highest trust in
government it's like north it's like
south korea not north korea south korea
japan
and then like and then like the european
in north america and it's like i wonder
and i think that that's that like you
need that base level so to me like the
answer to this puzzle i guess is
like we have to figure out how you get
that culture of trust
because without that culture of trust
any change you have is going to be
doomed to fail
like and and like there obviously is a
chicken in the egg problem here
but like i think you need that um you
need that to to come up with a with a
plan to foster that somehow and i'm not
exactly sure how
no look i talk classical political
thought at tech nine times and actually
the most popular modules that i thought
were
pills is probably gonna be shocked by
this but uh the feminist one was really
popular but the other two were rawls and
nozick because we did three weeks on the
debate between them and a lot of people
were really interested in this because
interest inequality was extremely high
among students right who should get why
how but the number one thing every
student mentioned uh when we talked
about how it is you could implement
either a libertarian society or a roles
in you know liberal socialist society
was yeah but i would never trust the
government to actually create
institutions like that like you actually
think that the state could organize
itself that way come on who are you
kidding right that was the uniform
objection made to this kind of ideal
theorizing was just that nobody trusted
uh institutions and nobody trusted their
neighbor to actually live by uh these
kinds of idealizations yeah and i
actually want to hear marian because i
know that she expressed to me if she is
willing to share
about some of her experience with more
like radical leftist like classmates
that would talk about certain things and
i don't know you had really interesting
things to say about that
yeah i guess maybe you can remind me
because sometimes i forget my own
thoughts but know what i was when i say
going back to pills question about well
what this romanticized version that
you're you know like your anarchist in
their mom's basement have about i think
that people fail to realize
because maybe i don't know their own
experience their own set of values isn't
latin america is a very socially
conservative region
like even you when you have your leftist
bros they might not they might be know
but like anti-abortion you know or like
why are you dressing like that as a
woman you know like
like
it's a regi at least mexico catholicism
it's like it's still practiced by 88 of
the population they might not go to like
church every sunday you know but they
still hold those values like dearly and
they play a huge role so i think
my unison is when people say it's like
oh let's overthrow all this and
we'll see what happens it's like well
but i do i for example first as a woman
do i want to be in the hands of these
very macho guys
first you know like do i want to be like
like do i want them calling the shots
because they have much more power right
you know like the people also disregard
the huge power especially economical
that um
they all the oligarchy has in latin
america right like and it's not only
mexico but like every latin american
country like has you know the oligarchy
and they are very powerful they also
call the shots a lot of the times you
know like so it's just like
um
i think
people fail to realize like the
complexities is like
like when they mean socialist utopia i
think they they they mean it in a very
like in in a vacuum of social relations
power relations that they don't know
they don't understand and that i think
if you leave if you don't live in the
region it's very
difficult that you're going to
understand them as you mentioned victor
like there's this mentality
that is also very present in mexico but
basically like the mentalities sometimes
people teach their kids which is very
like
it's very present as kind of like like
it's like a social value almost i think
or i don't know how to call it it's just
a cultural thing people will tell you
like [ __ ] them first before they [ __ ]
you over right and there is something
that you will like hear par install in
their kids and like it's like a like
it's past it's it's passing it over
right like that that's the the value
you're supposed to live by right like no
like like yes there might be solidarity
but it's like a very like
a very tentative solidarity like at this
one this is very interesting to me kind
of in a if when looking
anthropologically
into canadian society because a lot of
people like in mexico tell me oh but
like
like i don't know white people can be
like
just bill not that friendly and to a
certain extent i will agree but what
i've noticed is that people are mostly
respectful and they will just remain
like
coldly respectful
and
and and i feel that in latin america and
mexico specifically like people will be
overly friendly but the meaning they can
screw you over they will
at some point if they will advance them
and they will benefit them not that a
canadian will not do that but i feel
that the canadian not passed as your
friend tell you sorry if we did it yeah
i think that's sorry bro i think they
will they will never try to be your
friend they will just remain this in
this distance right it's not like these
but backstabbing that you will
definitely feel like i don't know in
that mexican context because the people
first will uh i pose as your friend so i
don't know like maybe i'm just like
stupidly over generalizing but i think
there is like uh yeah no like and i
think this mentality i'm not gonna blame
i think there are many things preventing
from like the left operating a change in
latin america it has to do with like
geopolitics like international like
division of power it has to do with as i
said with like the the social
conservatism of the region and as victor
said it also has largely to do with the
trust in the government right the people
don't trust the government so
i don't know this is going back to what
i was saying before like
when people say oh no we have to
decolonize our knowledge let's ditch
this whole idea of like liberal values
like trust is at the center of like the
liberal government in someone like locke
and when this is what i said but why
don't we want this in a country where no
one trusts anyone especially today that
there's so much violence because of the
cartels and the drug wars and etc
so
i don't know i i i i'll guess
this is not to say oh you will never
understand the region if you don't
travel there but my experience in canada
is that people are will like are very
willing to make these bold statements
because they come
from a country i was just reading these
statistics the other day about how
canadian cities rank among the cities
among cities in the world where people
are the mo feel that they are like
among the most trusting environments
like ottawa ranking and the highest of
like trust like cities that are
trustworthy
right and so when you come in from a
context like that it's very easy to say
oh no yeah like
like
let's bring now everything like yeah
this can happen but when you come from a
context where like
uh violence is so common like violence
violence against women is so common even
like
true language like
people think you can cut cold i have
never been caught calling canada ever
but like no like in mexico every [ __ ]
day even if i just go out for like five
minutes it will happen you know so i
don't think
people understand how like
i just want to interject on something
shocking that you said are you saying
that there are like marxists who don't
give a [ __ ] about feminism or even
anti-feminist like that's just shocking
to me i would never believe that there
could be such a thing and i'm actually
disgusted to hear you say that
they are everywhere they are just so
common in latin america
i i also was going to say you know i
think it could be easy for people to
hear what you just said
as like you know um
canadians leftists stop complaining you
have it so good here and like obviously
that's not what you're saying
uh you know like like it's just
like i think uh but but i think
i think that sometimes there can be a
fear on the left you're actually raising
something that i think is because i've
noticed it's kind of interesting
that there's like it's like in order
there's like this weird like
psychological complex in leftists where
like they feel like they need to remain
attached to like how bad everything is
otherwise they feel like their
mobilization's not going to be possible
so it's like we have to frame things as
negatively as possible and not
acknowledge any good things otherwise
the conservatives might win or
um it'll like lose steam and i think
like to me it's like you have to in
order to
think and strategize about like what is
actually going to be the best path
forward to make things better
i think you have to acknowledge like
what are the things we want to hang on
to and what are the things we want to
let go of and i think that one of the
things we want to hang on to is
basically like a culture of trust uh in
institutions and institutions that
basically function and like a rule of
law that basically functions like and to
talk about how actually that's a good
thing to have that it's like a maybe a
necessary
um foundation
to build on and and like so you know
yeah that's what i would say about that
all right we've been going for a long
time so why don't we rap on this uh
miriam you've been in canada for a year
and a half now if you could
correct the most annoying misconception
that
your classmates or people like us
have about latin america what do you
think that would be
i think there is still a lot of
i mean i don't want to call it like
orientalism because of course
like i don't know latin america operates
on that like limit of being western
but i think there's
there's still a lot of like
romanticization of what the real news i
think like uh and it's
somehow
upsetting because we are south of you
right like
like when sometimes i tell people that
like some
i hate it i hate it when people use
north america and they mean the us and
canada it's so annoying
there's a whole [ __ ] treaty sorry
nafta that was then dream negotiate
right
north america is mexico too right but of
course they caught us geographically
because it's like no north america means
white right and i think it's it speaks
of this very insular quality of of anglo
white anglo
canada and the u.s like the how they
wanna be
insulated from the rest of the country
that they see as an opportunity in terms
of resources but also as a problem in
terms of the people right i think uh
and not all people are the same i found
also like people genuinely interested in
the problems of the region but i think
there is this very
um
i don't know i think people use latin
america
at least my experience among uh
theorists and academics it says the the
you know in the way that best suits
their interests so when we have to be
radical they highlight like oh the
uh the zapatistas and you know the
gorillas and these and that but then
when it's about like oh
look at what corruption
does right or look at this like
uneducated i don't know like people
right and like i don't know i think
there's this very ambivalent position um
and
i honestly don't know the explanation
for it
uh
i'll say that it's i do agree that it's
a very competitive region like most of
my leftist sympathies were
like fueled by latin american leftism
like like
for sure right like i don't think that
there's any
lie in that but i think
like
where like a lot of the left today i
feel in latin america is looking like
after the 20th century experience of
trying to
overthrow the government today they've
recognized that probably the best way to
go is by
not overthrowing the government by
reforming and changing the government
right like like reform and i feel that
some people may be at least in in canada
are ignorant to that that that
like this leftism is no longer not all
of it
uh there are people of course more
radical but even the radical feminists
in my country they say they are radical
but it's like oh but we're asking the
state it's so funny like i find them
very funny that in that way right it's
like oh no we're radical but then they
want the justice of the state it's like
well if you were truly radical you were
you were to ask at least in my point of
view from a justice that is not the
state i don't know the state justice but
but whatever and it's also to
i think when they ignore these things
they kind of also like they don't help
their own cause i feel that they look at
like oh look at this like radical
leftist in nothing america but i think
maybe it can like like knowing more
about how actually the left works and
the history of the left as you were
saying with the documentary i think uh
kind uh can help
like what
some of the people are trying to achieve
here
that would be my my thing is like stop
just romanticizing and i actually tried
to learn about it which maybe that's
where um
like i don't know like the video comes
in and i was not saying that a white
person cannot make a video about latin
america at all just to go back to my
previous question it was just about like
i think um because in latin america is
very well like these things have been
documented talk about right but i think
um
it's not the case in like maybe canada
and the us right so i think as you were
saying this this is more of like a
educational tool and i can't see the
value in that because i've seen a lot of
ignorance among my classmates right and
they are a phd level and they just like
generalize in a way in ways that they
don't understand which is probably the
same that i do about canada right
there's so much that i still need to
learn
um
but then i don't know go i don't go out
and saying well i have the truth about
i've left this i mean canada has to do
right whereas they do hold the truth
about what the left should do everywhere
at every point right so
tim hortons snow
molson all you need is like one sense
game and get pissed off at the toronto
maple leafs losing and be canadian and
like and by pretty much any proxy i want
to say i agree with what you're saying
though actually the thing that annoys me
most about tankies in
north america is getting involved in
long story short north america oh sorry
i mean you mean
all right wes
you're one of them
thing that annoys me most about western
tankies are getting involved in long
stupid twitter debates about autocratic
or authoritarian leftist regimes in
latin america and trying to defend them
and
it always pisses me off because i'm like
it's never going to be a good look like
there's no way of painting some of these
things to give off a good impression if
you want to point to a good
administration point to lula ponto
morales you know pre-2015 i'd say uh
point some of the great stuff that's
being done by the zapatistas who i do
think actually are successfully
revolutionary movement in mexico don't
get involved and [ __ ] argument people
about venezuela don't be sitting there
saying well if only
cuba wasn't blockaded they wouldn't have
to torture so many people it's just a
dumb look don't do it
all right so
the documentary comes out on the 18th
it's already out but you got to pay for
it
but after the 18th you don't you know
milton freeman um
won the uh nobel prize for economics in
1976.
soon after this uh
here's a part of his speech as some of
you may know uh my monetary studies have
led me to the conclusion that central
banks could profitably be replaced by
computers geared to provide a steady
rate of growth in the quantity of money
so he he certainly learned something
from his uh stint in uh reforming chile
for the elites and
trying to create wealth for the uh top
20 what i want to know is what are those
buttons on those chairs and the picture
of the command room do
those summon um glasses of whiskey
yeah there's like triangle there's like
triangular buttons and like on like a
hex and like a pentagonal button and
they're just like that's just does that
do anything i think they control the uh
the screens on the walls and things like
that they bring up different slides and
they have little and and also the
whiskey button
the most crucial of them all
all right well why don't we wrap it
there marion trejo thanks so much for uh
joining us and the rest of you yep that
was that was good but long
all right see you later guys take care
there were large demonstrations against
me at the nobel ceremonies in stockholm
i remember seeing the same faces in the
crowd in a talk in chicago and a talk in
santiago
and there was no doubt that there were a
concerted effort to tar and feather me
[ __ ] milton freeman
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah he got
cancelled at the nobel prize ceremony
still won it still a [ __ ] [ __ ] who
ruined
chili at least
but yeah
[ __ ] that guy hyatt he loved hayek and
all that oh my god what a douchebag
[Music]
you